[Musique]
on retrouve Véronique prince Michel
David Chantal Hébert bonsoir bonsoir On
commence à les connaître par coeur les
chiffres je voulais montrer une dernière
fois le tableau d'augmentation donc qui
sera accordé si le projet de loi est
adopté 101 à 131 d'où le la question qui
revenait Véronique dans vos et les
questions de vos collègues 30 000 c'est
30 000 dollars de plus hausse de 21%, ce
que ça donne pour les différents postes
Premier ministre etc on les monte depuis
un certain nombre de jours c'est le
rapport que l'on que l'on accepte je
vous fais entendre monsieur Legault
rapidement l'opposition qu'on revient
tout de suite
[Musique]
il y a eu un comité indépendant c'est
penché sur le dossier pour que les
salaires soient compétitifs
ce qui surtout chacun le disons là c'est
plus l'empressement de d'adopter une
augmentation immédiate alors qu'il y a
des groupes des groupes de
gens qui sont importants pour la société
qui eux ça fait longtemps qu'ils
demandent qui demanderait qu'ils n'ont
pas de réponse c'est une question qui
devrait être traité de manière non
partisanale qui devrait faire l'objet du
plus grand consensus possible entre les
partis politiques je pense pas que la
carte peut avancer seul là-dessus on est
très mal à l'aise moi j'ai pas demandé
ça j'aurais fait tout le mandat sans
augmentation sans aucun problème
donc
QS et le Parti québécois Véronique son
compte est libéraux sont pour midi ça va
trop vite c'est comme si on voulait pas
manger le gâteau trop vite là moi je
dirais par contre faites attention aux
messages publics qui est lancé et ce que
certains députés pensent vraiment parce
que croyez-vous qu'ils vont aller dire
devant les caméras oui je la veux
l'augmentation de salaire mais je peux
vous dire qu'il y en a qui aimeraient
l'avoir effectivement parce qu'ils
disent je travaille sans relâche dans un
contexte politique et de plus en plus
intense la cape pourra pas aller toute
seule là dedans pour une question
d'image parce que oui elle est
majoritaire pourrait l'adopter le projet
de loi mais pour que ça ait l'air d'être
consensus faut au moins qu'il y a un
autre parti qui ait dans le même sens ça
va probablement être le Parti libéral
partie québécois est pas encore tout à
fait positionner c'est flou à savoir
s'ils vont ils ont l'air d'être contre
mais ce qu'ils vont voter contre on sait
pas encore Québec soldat dans son cas
c'est clair qu'ils vont être contre je
vais juste se terminer en vous disant
une chose il y a seulement deux articles
dans le projet de loi pensez-y là on
part en relâche parlementaire la semaine
prochaine il reste trois semaines après
on va être dans le tourbillon de tous
les autres projets de loi qu'il faut
adopter alors deux articles ça veut dire
Chop Chop on fait le débat très
rapidement on passe à autre chose le
plus discrètement possible ça compense
pour la réforme de la santé vous ditiez
hier ça sera certainement pas avant de
la fin de l'été qui est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour le gouvernement il y a à
peu près 300 000
Michel est-ce que bon ça va passer ça
c'est je pense qu'il y a pas de question
là-dessus que ça laisse des traces
est-ce que dans le fond se rattrapage là
vous estimez qu'il était mérité
objectivement c'est vrai que les députés
ont une charge de travail très lourde et
qui a toutes sortes de conditions de
travail ou d'environnement de travail
qui sont pas faciles bon la conciliation
famille travail les réseaux sociaux en
fait on comprend tout ça mais fixer une
rémunération c'est aussi un exercice
d'équité voyez-vous
la rémunération et encore pire si on
inclut le régime de pension là dans le
projet de loi ne parle pas cette
rémunération là va faire en sorte que
les députés de l'Assemblée nationale
vont être nettement plus payés que ceux
des autres assemblées législatives
j'exclus le la Chambre des communes dans
les autres provinces canadiennes or il y
a pas de pénurie de personnels
politiques vous savez on n'a pas de nous
heures en trouver puis il y a j'entends
personne dire je lâche la job parce que
c'est pas assez payant alors que des des
enseignants des infirmières qui sont
moins payés que la moyenne canadienne
manque cruellement alors pourquoi on a
les moyens de payer nos députés plus
chers que ceux des autres provinces mais
qu'on n'a pas les moyens de payer nos
enseignants aussi chers que ceux des
autres provinces alors il y a quand même
une
bonne question à se poser Chantal et là
il y a un double timing on comprend que
c'est le genre de projet de loi qu'on
veut faire passer au plus vite au début
d'un mandat pour qu'on en reparle plus
et en passant quand Jean Chrétien a
augmenté considérablement le salaire des
députés à Ottawa ça a fait du bruit le
temps que ça passe mais on en a jamais
entendu parler parce que à moins de
refuser l'augmentation de salaire il y a
pas d'autres parties qui allaient dire
on a accepté l'augmentation de salaire
et on l'a dénonce mais l'autre le
problème du timing de faire vite c'est
que ça tombe en même temps justement que
des négociations salariales pour des
employés Michel ledi qui ne sont pas
payés à l'échelle de de la moyenne
canadienne alors là quelque part et le
gouvernement d'une main se tire dans le
pied à la table de négociation en
faisant ça parce que si on a l'argent
pour les députés pourquoi on l'a pas
pour les employés essentiels qu'on
essaye d'attirer
ils vont ils vont je pense qu'il y a un
chiffre Véronique c'est 3 millions le
coût de ces de ces augmentations sur un
plan annuel avoir je m'en vais à terroir
justement parlant de moyenne canadienne
je m'en vais à ta voix le gouvernement
qui prend
ces distances de cette fameuse
initiative du siècle dont on a parlé
beaucoup en début de semaine
100 millions à 2100 millions de
personnes d'habitants au Canada 2016 on
écoute un échange entre à l'intérieur et
le ministre fraiseux ils écoutaient là
je voulais c'est pas notre politique on
écoute
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté pas une
pas deux trois motions uneanimes contre
ces cibles tous les élus du Québec sont
contre c'est pas parce que c'est des
méchants nationalistes c'est parce qu'il
n'acceptent pas une transformation aussi
radicale du Québec sans débat et sans
leur avis le gouvernement s'engager à ne
pas aussi l'immigration jusqu'à 100
millions de citoyens en 2100 les plaines
pour le nécessitent du siècle n'est pas
les politiques de notre gouvernement
mais c'est possible c'est important
c'est essentiel de accueillir des
nouveaux arrivants et protéger les ports
démographiques de francophones en même
temps
le ministre Chantal qui dit le plan
l'initiative du siècle n'est pas la
politique canadienne mais il faut quand
même dire que vous voyez le graphique
2020 jusqu'à 2030 l'augmentation
annoncée par Ottawa correspond à la
volonté de ce groupe privé d'initiative
du siècle Chantal est-ce que le
gouvernement venait à moins prendre ses
distances
l'initiative du siècle je pense que tout
le monde à Ottawa pensait que c'était
mort et enterrer c'est un fait que le
gouvernement de Justin Trudeau a fait
rien d'autre que de dire merci de la
recommandation du bout des lèvres et
jusqu'à cette semaine on en avait jamais
entendu parler même pas comme une cible
à laquelle on aspirait est-ce que ça
veut dire que le gouvernement de Justin
Trudeau veut pas augmenter les cibles en
immigration ça c'est un débat
complètement différent et là-dessus
comme Monsieur le Gaulle sait très bien
le gouvernement Trudeau réagi aux
pressions des provinces l'Ontario la
Colombie Britannique sont partantes
entre autres mais pas exclusivement pour
des cibles plus élevés alors c'est pas
le gouvernement fédéral dans un silo
tout seul qui a dit on va augmenter ce
serait donc amusant d'avoir plus
d'immigrants ça correspond aussi à la
volonté de la majorité des provinces à
l'extérieur du Québec donc Michel quand
on en a beaucoup parlé cette semaine
ces chiffres extrapolis sur plusieurs
années
montrez que Québec poursuive la cadence
aurait dû accueillir de vrais accueillir
120 000 130 000 immigrants monsieur
fraiseux rappelle ou en tout cas le dit
plus clairement que jamais c'est pas
notre politique peut-être les deux
prochaines années oui mais avoir
qu'est-ce que vous comprenez dans ce
mouvement d'abord je comprends que c'est
gênant pour un gouvernement de
d'admettre qui se fait imposer une
politique aussi importante par un groupe
de pression ou on retrouve des gens
comme le PDG de mécanic etc alors ça un
gouvernement peut pas admettre comme ça
qu'il est dans le fond à la sole disons
des du marché du travail mais pour le
Québec la réalité ne change pas on verra
dans 10 ans si les subs sont encore là
mais ce qui a été annoncé l'automne
dernier par Monsieur Fey c'est à bien
500 000 par année à compter de 2025
alors ça c'est la réalité à la le Québec
est confronté actuellement alors ça ce
qu'on disait mardi est aussi vrai deux
jours plus tard c'est-à-dire que le
Québec va devoir choisir entre suivre le
mouvement et accueillir des immigrants
qui le tout des chances de ne pas être
capable d'intégrer en aussi grand nombre
ou dire on maintient nos soeurs beaucoup
plus bas et on se fait petit à petit
noyer dans la Fédération alors pour le
Québec ce que Monsieur Frégé nous a dit
aujourd'hui ça ça fait pas ça ça fait
pas de différence ça c'est ce qu'on
enlève le côté spectaculaire de 2100
mais en 2025 les cibles du gouvernement
je parle pas du groupe du gouvernement
sont sont 500 000 Véronique et ce à quoi
Québec répond on peut pas suivre
de dire que pour le Québec en fait
peut-être que le gouvernement Trudeau se
dit aussi l'initiative du siècle mais
pour ce qui est des principes aux yeux
Québec ça demeure les mêmes puis il va
falloir composer avec de toute façon
peut-être aussi que le gouvernement
Trudeau a fait des sondages ou à
vérifier un coup de son dans les
derniers jours c'est peut-être aperçu
que le terme initiative du siècle et ça
passait moins bien donc peut-être que de
ce côté-là aussi c'est une des raisons
pourquoi ils ont voulu sans distancer
mais du côté de Québec ça change
absolument rien aujourd'hui ok on
s'entend là les mots initiatives du
siècle avant cette semaine en français
on les entendait pas c'est pas un
vocabulaire qui s'appelle adopté et donc
ils viennent de se départir
maintenant cela dit j'ai écouté le débat
aujourd'hui j'ai pas entendu le Parti
conservateur dire qu'il était pas
partant pour des cibles élevées en
matière d'immigration que j'ai pas
entendu le NPD le dire non plus bon ben
justement quand il dit monsieur
poirievre aujourd'hui il a dit qu'il
appuyait une motion du Bloc québécois
monsieur pollièvre je vous donne le
contexte la motion du Bloc
sur l'initiative du siècle la motion du
Bloc québécois le
service augmenté la population
canadienne à 100 millions si 2100 dit la
motion du Bloc et là ils disent ça peut
pas être fait comme ça écoutez monsieur
Poirier qui réagit au bloc
c'est comme ça quoi le gouvernement
mené par moi conservateur de gros bon
sens voire repérer le dommage c'est pour
laquelle je vais voter pour cette motion
pour rejeter d'omniparton et
l'initiative du siècle et rebaser le
système d'immigration sur le gros bon
sens de monsieur et madame tout le monde
est-ce que le sous-tête Chantal c'est de
ne pas envoyer comme message quand même
au Québec particulièrement moi je vais
en accueillir moins là
j'ai hâte de voir le jour où le
gouvernement conservateur s'il existe
pas établir ces cibles s'il va y avoir
une différence mais un parti
monsieur poilliev dans le moment est en
train de faire du démarcheur à des
marchés qui ont des aspirations
différentes alors
je ne crois pas qu'un gouvernement
conservateur dirait au gouvernement de
l'Ontario ou à celui du Manitoba on va
recevoir pas mal moins d'immigrants même
si vous en voulez pas respecter le poids
du Québec dans fédération canadienne
moi aussi je pense que le sous-texte il
faut faire attention ça a l'air de dire
nous on va réviser ça la baisse mais ça
a pas été dit de façon formelle alors
souvenez il y a quelqu'un qui avait dit
on met notre serre nos sièges enjeux
pour qu'il y ait du changement mais
personne n'avait compris que le
changement était celui-là alors tant que
Monsieur et poilliev sera pas plus
explicite le doute demeure ouais
Véronique c'est intéressant à l'aube de
congrès de la CAQ qui commence à
Sherbrooke demain monsieur Legault on a
l'impression que c'est presque un
copier-coller par rapport à l'an dernier
là il va beaucoup parler de ça et c'est
sûr que les questions des médias vont
être beaucoup orientés vers ça mais d'un
autre côté je ne suis pas certaine que
l'initiative va venir de monsieur
Legault parce que quand je lis le cahier
des participants le programme tout ça
moi je pense qui s'attendent à avoir des
questions sur l'immigration puis tant
mieux s'ils en ont monsieur logo est
prêt à répondre puis envie de répondre
parce qu'il veut rappeler que son parti
et nationaliste qu'il est le défenseur
du Québec s'il parle d'immigration mais
là à ce moment-là ce sera l'occasion de
le faire en fait ce congrès de la façon
qu'on peut le voir là c'est que ça a été
un début de mandat difficile puis ça va
être un point tournant en tout cas les
caquistes espèrent c'est à dire que le
samedi ça va pas remettre une journée
difficile on va revenir sur le troisième
lien l'abandon de la promesse est-ce que
les militants sur place les délégués
sont déçus de ça qu'en de toutes les
politiques d'immigration et tout ça puis
le dimanche ben là ça va être pour dire
regardez là nous on est nationalistes on
vous rappelle notre identité on vous
rappelle qu'on est pour la transition
énergétique c'est comme ça qu'on veut
finir la session puis partir pour l'été
Michel David qu'est-ce que veut faire
monsieur le goût en fin de semaine
Michel moi je pense que monsieur Legault
veut comment dire tourner la page sur
les dernières semaines l'abandon du
troisième lien et toute toutes les
questions qu'on lui pose tous les jours
qui tient pas ses promesses en santé et
en éducation et là je pense que monsieur
Legault veut dire écouter là on passe un
bout difficile mais l'avenir est radieux
ceci étant dit
les députés les délégués disent je
comprends qui ont été déçus mais ils
vont aussi fêter c'est le premier gros
rassemblement depuis la victoire de
l'automne dernier et je pense que on
obtiendra pas grief beaucoup à monsieur
Legault de ce qui se passe et même de
l'AB troisième lien on va le voir il y a
un vote de confiance la dernière fois il
y avait eu 97%, je rebaisse surpris que
ça soit en boîte 95 cette fois-ci
Chantal et quelque part ce débat sur
l'immigration qui a été animée ailleurs
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale dans un
premier temps ça tombe bien pour changer
de sujets de conversation et un peu
évacuer la question du troisième lien
mais je suis comme Michel je m'attends
pas à ce que dimanche monsieur Legault
partent en réflexion parce que son score
d'approbation va être trop bas
monsieur Bouchard le samedi soir à
Québec
était déçu de son score dans une autre
vie Maxime Bernier candidat au Manitoba
tour de table Chantal Hébert mais
j'allais dire on l'avait presque oublié
mais en tout cas élections partielles
donc c'était le un siège a-t-il des
chances que veut-il faire ou ou est-il
bon d'abord il est là puisqu'on en parle
donc ça a déjà réussi ça a déjà marché
son affaire ensuite le Manitoba c'est la
province rappelez-vous où il s'était
fait arrêter parce que il participait à
des manifestations anti-vaccin
la circonscription n'auriez question
c'est un château fort conservateur c'est
aussi la circonscription ou une de deux
circonscriptions où sont partis a eu le
meilleur score aux dernières élections
c'est à dire 22%
et ça embête profondément pierre Poirier
parce que de deux choses l'une ou bien
Maxime Bernier fait patate et ça règle
son cas ou bien il sort de là avec un
score respectable et là tous les députés
commencent à s'inquiéter de ce que le
parti de Maxime Bernier pourrait leur
faire avec les gens de discours que ça
guest mais entraîné alors dans un cas
comme dans l'autre si monsieur Bernier
se le dit réussit pas à avoir un score
honorable
ça pourrait l'amener à décliner une fois
pour toute Michel je connais pas la
circonscription mais on l'a décrit comme
une des plus conservatrices de l'Ouest
s'ils ont réussi à faire les
conservateurs ont quand même facilement
pris ce compte-là avec plus de 50% avec
avec Monsieur auto alors ces gens-là
trouvaient que Monsieur auto il était un
petit peu trop au centre là ils vont
être contents d'avoir monsieur Poirier
alors j'anticipe pas une grosse percée
de monsieur Bernier là l'impression
qu'il va faire moins bien que que le
candidat de son parti avait fait à la
dernière élection générale ouais ce qui
serait peut-être pas la fête
ça serait pas bon mouvement vers unique
pour lui oui moi je trouve ça super
intéressant à suivre en fait parce que
c'est un test vous allez me dire
toujours une un test une partiel mais
c'est un test pour Maxime Bernier de
voir est-ce que son message libertarien
il est encore capable d'aller chercher
des gens dans quelle mesure puis le test
pour Pierre poliev c'est de voir
maintenant qu'il est plus à droite que
c'est prédécesseur mais quelle frange il
est toujours pas capable d'aller
chercher s'il y en a une donc c'est pour
ça que je trouve ça très intéressant un
test là mais c'est fan à suivre voilà
ben merci beaucoup Véronique Michel
Chantal bonne soirée à très bientôt au
revoir